salut et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de film actu votre émission
hebdomadaire sur l'actualité du cinéma
du Blu-ray et du DVD si Charl h ce jeu
d'ombre est bien sûr la sortie
immanquable de cette semaine nous ne
manquons pas de vous parler également de
the descendant avec en tête d'affiche le
beau George Clounet Jack et Julie avec
Lilar Adam
et du très beau Café de Flore avec
Vanessa Paradis du côté des sorties
vidéo TR titres ont retenu notre
attention destination final 5 la guerre
est déclaré et la comédie mais comment
font les femmes avec Sarah Jessica
Parker mais avant cela faisons un point
sur les chiffres du box
office bon comme ça c'est un petit
événement pour la prière fois depuis moi
intouchable n'est plus le roi du box
office du moins cette semaine en effet
malgré ces 500000 nouvelles entrées le
film d'Eric Toledano et d'Olivier nakche
a dû s'incliner devant le succès de
Jedgar de clinttiswood et ses 630000
spectateurs cela dit on vous rappelle
qu'intouchable dépasse aujourd'hui les
18300000 entrées au total ça
voilà aux États-Unis les nouveautés font
ell aussi la loi puisque les deux
premières places du box office sont
trusté par Underworld 4 et Red TS la
dernière production de George
Lucas que
voyez-vous
tout voilà mon fléo Brigant de tout gen
trembler car Sherlock Holmes est de
retour toujours incarné par le génial
Robert Dony jor le le détective le plus
futé de Sa Majesté reprend du service
dans une nouvelle aventure baptisée
charerlock Holmes jeu d'ombre
qu'avons-nous à affronter cette fois
l'âme criminelle la plus redoutable
d'Europe à travers une enquête qui les
mèneront en France en Allemagne et en
Suisse sherlock Holmes et son fidèle
bras droit Watson se lanceront à la
poursuite du sinistre moriarti vos
secondes sont comptées tout aussi
spectaculaire que le premier épisode ce
Sherlock Holmes 2 vous entraînera dans
de folles péripéties ponctué de nombreux
rebondissements élémentaires pas tant
que ça fait
mouche mes amis s'imaginent que parce
que j'habite à Hawai je vis au Paradis
mdames mesdemoiselles cette émission est
faite pour vous puisqueaprès Robert Dony
jor et judelot place à George Clounet et
son nouveau film The
descendant j'ai toujours été le parent
de remplacement avec Elizabeth à
l'hôpital et meilleur film dramatique de
l'année il y a quelques jours lors de la
cérémonie des Golden globs ce disendad
raconte l'histoire d'un père de famille
qui va partir à la recherche de la mort
de sa femme en compagnie de ses de de
filles parfois drôle souvent touchante
cette comédie dou sa mère est l'un des
films majeurs de l'année et surtout l'un
des grands prétendants aux
Oscars récupère Julie demain à 4h du
matin elle ne vient qu'une fois par an
et elle repart dimanche parce qu'une
comédie avec Adam Sandler ça ne loupe
jamais découvrez cette semaine sur votre
écran le film Jack et Julie la nouvelle
pitrerie hilarant du roi de la comédie
américaineage balade à
cheval c'est quoi ça dans cette
truculante comédie Adam Sendler incarne
un homme qui ne supporte plus sa sœur
jumelle et qui va tout essayer pour la
faire dégarpir de sa maison c'est du
délire punaise faut que tu lui
téléphones en campant deux rôles
différents Adam Sendler nous prouve une
fois de plus qu'il n'a pas son pareil à
Hollywood pour nous faire
rire après l'inoubliable crazy et le
très bon Victoria les jeunes années
d'une reine le réalisateur canadien
Jean-Marc Valy nous revient avec café de
Flore
le film nous raconte les destins croisés
de Jacqueline une jeune parisienne
incarnée par Vanessa Paradis etantoine
un DJ monéal C par Kin
par un film d'amour tout simplement
bouleverant n'aime pas se faire berner
parce que la mort ne prend jamais de RTT
voilà que déboules cette semaines dans
nos bacs DVD et Blu Ray le 5e épisode de
la saga Destination Finale la mort vient
les prendre la recette est connue de
tous mais fonctionne toujours à
merveille et cet opus plus spectaculaire
encore que ses prédécesseurs ne manquera
pas de vous faire sursauter de votre
siège âme sensible
s'abstenir parmi les films français de
l'année 2011 il a et intouchable bien
sûr mais aussi la guerre est déclarée
qui a illuminé l'été de nombreux
spectateur en août dernier réalisé par
valez la guerre est déclaré raconte
l'histoire d'un couple celui de Roméo et
Juliette et de leur enfant Adam touché
par une forme rare de
cancer poignant et audacieux la guerre
est déclaré un grand film d'amour à ne
manquer sous aucun prétexte j'aurais
jamais pu VI avec quelqu'un d'autre que
to Jackhammer du bureau de New York a
flashé sur une des proposition et veut
rencontrer l'UR Kate est marié a deux
enfants et un job épuisant elle passe sa
vie à jongl avec un emploi du temps de
ministre pour accorder son travail avec
l'éducation de ses enfants et sa vie de
couple mais comment fait-elle pour tout
concilier et bien c'est la question que
se pose le film Mais comment font les
femmes je sais pas comment vous faites
je ne sais pas comment tu fais je sais
pas comment elle fait drôle est souvent
bien pensé cette comédie doit beaucoup
au charme de sa comédienne principale la
pétillante Sarah Jessica Parker que
l'onait pas vu aussi en forme depuis la
série Sex and city un excellent
divertissement prère coupe de cheveux je
rate tout ce qui est
important voilà film actu émission c'est
tout pour aujourd'hui la semaine
prochaine nous vous retrouverons pour
évoquer les sorties de la vérité siement
3 de Tucker Andale fight le mal ainsi
que des sorties en vidéo d'un heureux
événement et de Crazy Stupid Love d'ici
là bonne séance à
tous